[Musica]
no
ma il sonno merlino puntato perviene
questo rumore non senti berlino c'è un
telefono che squilla non è il mio
telefono sembra che venga da dalla
scatola
vi ricordate cosa è successo l'ultima
volta che ho preso qualcosa dalla
scatola che non deve essere aperta è
meglio che faccio finta di niente e non
la pro magari posso aprirla solo per
spegnere la sveglia al telefono ma senza
tirare fuori niente dalla scatola cosa
ne pensate voi
tu che ne pensi berlino berlino al tonno
e fa bene ho deciso che aprirà la
scatola sono per spegnere la sveglia o
il telefono e poi la richiude e non la
riaprirò mai più
almeno faccio a smettere questo suono
fastidioso
un telefono proviamo a spegnere
si ma
è un vecchio telefono come si spegnerà
ma aspetta un momento i vecchi telefoni
non dovrebbero essere attaccati alla
presa tramite un cavo c'è solo un cavo
per la cornetta che strano vediamo se
riesco a spegnerlo
ma dietro ci sono dei pulsanti no non
funziona forse va a battere ma non si
può aprire qua
capisco come fa a funzionare
provo staccare questo cavo
ok forse ora non sfilerà più o no ma
come faccia a farlo smettere come faccio
spegnerlo e ciao ciao marino che stai
facendo niente stavamo guardando dei
video su youtube lasciamo fuori io ho
messo pure il cappello ma anche per la
giornata che accese un solo è magnifico
beh sì effettivamente una bellissima
giornata così che cos'era pezzo
no penso che sia giocare pronto chi è
penso che hanno sbagliato numero
ma mi stai nascondendo una cosa o che
cosa dovrei nasconderti
se sì perché non mi disse andare fuori
giardino e ti raggiungo subito ok ok
portò merlino con me allora ok dai
berlino hanno genere fuori siamo
c'è mancato pochissimo che è vitale mi
scopriste anzi neanche accorto che la
scatola equa ed è aperto a meno male non
se n'è accorto perché gli avevo promesso
che non avrei mai più riaperta per
fortuna non si è accorto che avevo
questo telefono un ascolto dietro alla
schiena
ora che cosa faccio come faccio a farlo
smettere di suonare o un'idea prendo la
scatola e rimetto il telefono nella
scatola e la richiuso sperando che
sparisca come le altre cose ha
funzionato non squilla più o no mi
sembrava troppo facile
che cosa devo fare per farlo sparire
farlo smettere
forse devo per forza rispondere ea bene
secondo voi dovrei rispondere questo
telefono se l'unica opzione per farlo
smettere a rispondere risponderò
controlliamo che vitale non ci stia
guardando ok un tale non sta guardando
provo a rispondere al telefono ma prima
lasciate un mi piace questo figlio va
sotto per rispondere devo riattaccare la
cornetta
spero che funzioni ancora proviamo a
rispondere
[Musica]
pronto a mio agio
ma che sta facendo anita vita che
succeda più visto cadere dalla finestra
cadere
no mi sono solo seduta per terra
più freddo ma si sicura che stai bene ti
vedo un po strana stanca ma non
benissimo ha un sito perchè non vai a
mangiare qualcosa che ne penti mangiare
qualcosa sempre bene io vado subito
allora ok ciao dovuto se c'è mancato
pochissimo che è vitale mi scoprisse per
fortuna è sempre molto distratto e non
si è accorto della scatola aperta lì e
di questo telefono qual è il terra che
stavo cercando di nascondere con i piedi
ma merli non se n'è accorto
ricchiuti a muro subito ecco fatto lo
richiuso ora lo rimetto subito chiudiamo
la scatola limitino l'acqua e facciamo
finte non sia successo niente di tale
non deve scoprire che ori e aperto la
scatola non avrei dovuto prenderlo non
avrei dovuto rispondere berlino cosa
devo fare dimmelo tu berlino no no no no
no non aprire quella scatola che è molto
pericolosa
forza rispondere nuovamente altrimenti
non smetterà più a spiegarmi altrimenti
tornerà vitale e si accorgerà che ore ha
aperto la scatola pronto
[Musica]
pronto non capisco chi sei pronto pronto
ora basta visitare la casa di questo
telefono
[Musica]